we have this guy who calls into the show
every once in a while we haven't heard
from him for months his name is Troy
York he calls in with different
characters one of them is I believe
Jamal Jenkins who is a black character
he has another one named Ramon Ramos who
is his Hispanic character you can tell
that he doesn't know what's going on
because he pronounces the name
Ramos which is of course not the way
that that last name is pronounced in
Spanish which is Ramos the emphasis on
the a here is Troy York as Ramone Ramos
as he says asking if I think Baltimore
is so great in relation to Donald
Trump's recent comments why didn't my
family move to Baltimore when we came to
the United States from Argentina
take a listen to Troy / Ramon Ramon
course is for you I know you came like
it's immigrant like be from Latin
America and you came from Israel and
Argentina one of those countries I think
ladies they are to see the foot I
believe you could be crying national I
noticed that you did not would you
emigrate if you did not consider the
city of Baltimore or a residency and
wondered why if it promptly is because
some what Trump said was the truth yeah
no in fact we didn't consider any place
other than the one town which had a
hospital at which my dad got a job so
it's actually far less exciting and
interesting than that
and I hate to break it to you it was not
there we didn't consider Santa Barbara
California which is just a beautiful
place we didn't consider Miami Beach
which I love we didn't consider you know
Montreal which is not the United States
but it's just such a lovely city that I
love we were in western Massachusetts
because that's where my dad got a job
and that's basically the full story okay
we have a tremendous bonus show this is
actually funny the stories on today's
bonus show are the same
that I promoted yesterday because
yesterday we had our biannual tech
Fiasco wherein the bonus show imploded
if you've never seen video recordings
implode it's a sight to behold the
yesterday's bonus show imploded and we
lost it we lost the bonus show I
explained it in full on yesterday's
bonus show so today we really are going
to talk about the Magga hat wearing kids
250 million dollar lawsuit has been
dismissed obviously because it was bogus
from day one fitness trackers like the
one I wear turns out that the 10,000
step goal may be overblown if one is
trying to achieve maximum health benefit
and we will also talk about economists
are now saying that Donald Trump's
administration is overpaying farmers for
trade losses we already talked about how
farmers are being destroyed by Donald
Trump's tariffs on China and other
places and we also talked about how it
is almost like a form of socialism which
Donald Trump claims to oppose to pay the
farmers for their trade losses and now
we're learning that it appears as though
the administration is actually
overpaying farmers for those trade
losses so we will talk about all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show leave me a voicemail if you like at
two one nine to david p send an email if
you want using the contact form on our
website but most importantly get access
to the bonus show by becoming a member
at WWJ pakman.com or by becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show I'll speak to you then